so we're here at Stax Music Academy but
you've also been posting a lot from the
recording studio yourself so does that
mean new music on the way hopefully soon
hopefully you know you know to be honest
I just called my publishers and I said
you know I just want to work with with
young fresh people and I want to
collaborate more and
you know I've been songwriting and
producing for so long I want to I want
to experience that energy and I want to
work with people that that I think are
truly you know amazing and those OH came
by worked with scissor the other day and
just worked with Meek Mill and I'm
having these experiences that are
fueling me in such a different way and
again I think it was really birthed out
of feeling like what can I do right now
to just be a part of my community and
integrate those oh and I met at the
funny enough at the Songwriters Hall of
Fame and I was like I'm such a fan if
you ever want to write and she was shy I
think she thought I was lying but we got
in and and we got a couple of ideas I
don't know when they're gonna come out
but they're pretty good I mean I'm not
gonna tell you too much about what we
did together in the studio if she wants
to tell you she can but it's Blaine's
it is so good I'm so excited about it
justin is one busy man not only is he
working on new music he's created an
entire song lab in collaboration with
Levi's at Stax Music Academy in Memphis
Tennessee and e.t got an exclusive look
so tell me about this room and it's
called the song lab yeah this is what
we're doing in here this is this is what
we this is what we made yeah you know
and this is a song lab but this is not
the only one I mean this is this is
specific to these instruments and and
but there's other rooms too where they
get to work with things like you know
this hooked up to their their laptops
and they can make they can program music
as well so we want to real
I want them to I want them to make live
music and sequence music and bring it
all together and make music that fuels
them
we're here at Stax Music Academy and
it's important to remember how it
changed the world really and but I also
want these kids to be able to make their
music as well I want them I want them to
be able to cover Aretha Franklin and
Otis Redding but I also want them to be
able to sample them and like turn it
into something else
this room is specific to instruments but
they have other rooms to lay there all
got their headphones on and they're
making games
thank you honestly I've learned so much
in the last 48 hours I feel like I'm
like I'm like fueled up and ready to get
back in the studio
[Music]
[Applause]